the most important traits of successful
venture capitalist is getting lucky
early what happens when you get lucky
early is everybody tells you You're
great just like some kid on the
basketball CT hits a three-pointer and
they're like wow you won the game with a
three-pointer you're an incredible
three-point shooter and the kid comes
back and starts shooting more threes and
then somebody says I got a coach for you
and who specializes in three-pointers
and I watch some videos and you get
momentum that happened to me with the
Uber investment because people are like
you're the guy who did Uber and Robin
Hood and Comm more Founders wanted to
work with me more LPS wanted to work
with me and The credibility went well I
think that's pretty common among most
investing disciplines if you
underperform interal years you won't
make it for the next few years